um like i i think that
that our economy in my opinion is
becoming increasingly
inhuman and punitive and like veering
off to like uh this rightward
direction uh and my big goal is to try
and humanize it
and i feel like what you're doing with
this human-centered storytelling is
trying to drag us
in this direction um in a positive way
i feel like the world needs much much
more of it the world would use i could
use like a legion of cheryl housers even
though that's impossible because you're
like this unique
um figure and and unicorn um and
one of my goals and having this
conversation really was for you to try
and impart some of what makes you
you want to like other folks who want to
be you and i know there are many people
listening to this or watching this who
are thinking like wow this woman's
amazing
um so yeah that that just wanted to lay
out that that was like the
um the impossible goal i'd set
for myself for this conversation yeah
but andrew you that's my profound
gratitude for
um everything you've done and who you
are
oh well i feel the same about you andrew
you know that
but and and you know you say the
caricature of you
is you know maybe that like you know the
math guy
but we all know that's not who you are i
mean why
did you you you you risked so much and
you you know you left your family for
two years and you
like went on on this campaign trail
because you
you had a calling you were driven
because you were so
empathetic to what you saw happening in
our country so you you engaged your big
brain to see
look at the data and see what was
happening but then you engaged your big
heart
to say i see what's happening and i
can't let it happen i have to take
action
and in your taking action you stirred
everyone else to follow you in
solidarity
to change what's happening and that's
what i try to do with storytelling
um the same thing to to create action in
solidarity but you know you ask in your
book and
your your slogan was humanity first and
now your humanity forward and
in your book you ask what makes us human
what makes us human is our ability to
love
to feel to care to have empathy to feel
empathy
and you know um in all of the you know
there's this
this guy um paul zach who's done a ton
of studies in the lab
around storytelling and around the
oxytocin and the cortisol
but he you know one of his studies he
would play a video of a father talking
to up to the camera about his son
who's two and dying of cancer and um
and uh it it follows that hero's journey
of this of this
the father's i have to be strong for him
and then at the end
and he he's taking people's oxytocin the
beginning the end
you know cortisol of that at the end of
that story he asks do you want to
donate some of the money you're being
paid to be in this study
to a a charity that gives money to um
for children with cancer and
the higher levels of oxytocin that
people have in their blood
uh indicated they would give more money
i mean it's
and then the people who did give money
felt warm and fuzzy after giving the
money
and the people who didn't didn't which
we also know
that when we give we benefit so much so
this is what
like i want to move people in telling
stories
to have the warm and fuzzy feeling and
then you know and to be fired up to take
action
um and you say it all the time you know
and which is why
you talk about like how dire things are
but you also give everyone hope you have
a vision of what
society could be if we can tap into our
humanity
and tap into and get that oxytocin
flowing and get the you know
more of the optimism and the love and
the caring
and empathy and all of those things so
it
you know it is it is a self like
love begets love hope begets hope and we
know when people are hopeful and
optimistic
what they're capable of they can start
to take risk and
um see their potential and reach for
their potential
if people have the men's uh mentality of
scarcity as you talk about
their all they can think about is like
survival
survival mode and then you can't think
about caring for others and loving
others and all of those other things
so anyway i mean there is a corollary
between what you're trying to do in
politics
and what i try to do with storytelling
um
then it all comes down to humanity and
what makes us human and bringing out the
humanity
in us because that's when we are our
best selves
now that makes me really proud that you
think we're doing the same kind of work
cheryl that makes me very happy
um you know it is about dialing up
humanity
um i have a question for you that i
don't know if we've ever discussed this
really but when i i told you i was
running for president and i said hey
when you make this
campaign video like what did you really
think
um i remember i'll never forget the
moment when you told me you were running
for president
we were at um an event screening at
grand central tech
and um it was you had just
uh sold your book uh the war on normal
people you hadn't started to write the
war on normal people
and um if the people were were watching
the movie and whenever
we were at these event screenings
together when people watched the movie
it was a time for us to catch up which
was wonderful and you said i'm going to
run for president
and you know what i said to you what i
have
would say to my children when they told
me they were going to do things that
sounded kind of crazy
i said that's amazing i said andrew
go for it first of all because i knew
you well by then and i saw how you had
built venture for america so fast
and i knew that you more than anyone
i've ever met
can will things into being and this is
also storytelling
the stories we tell ourselves either
propel us
or hold us back so you know um
we filmed with cassandra who was born a
congenital amputee
and her whole life told herself and
other people told her
you only have one arm you cannot be a
nurse she wanted to be a nurse
she was told you cannot be a nurse you
only have one arm and then
when she got onto social media
and saw that there were other people
with one arm who were nurses
if you can't see it you can't be it she
realized wow
i can be a nurse and when she told
herself i can be a nurse
she figured out how to make that happen
you are someone who tells yourself
i am going to do this i can do this and
then you make it happen
you just will it into existence and that
is also the power of storytelling the
stories we tell ourselves
and so when you said i'm gonna run for
president
i thought okay it's crazy but andrew
is he's gonna do it i mean i i didn't
think you were gonna be our candidate
but i did think that you were gonna make
a lot of noise and that you were gonna
reach your goal
of making universal basic income and
automation and all the things and uh you
know looking at a
different way to measure progress in our
in our society that you were going to
make them
part of the public you know discourse
um throughout the campaign and onwards
and and so it
you know you really have done that and
you continue to do that through humanity
forward which is
and yang speaks and everything you're
doing so um
again what did i think i thought this is
so bold this is so crazy
if anyone can pull off success whatever
success is going to look like it's
andrew if anyone has the
guts to do this it's andrew and when you
call when
i remember when you asked me to do the
video you called you got my voicemail
and you left a message and you said hey
cheryl it's andrew calling
i have a favor to ask can you call me
back and i knew it's like
okay andrew wants me to make his
campaign i knew it
i just knew it and i thought i
am honored i would be honored that's
what i thought i am drew
well well you definitely uh delivered
you know you called back and said yeah
let's do it which i was endlessly
grateful for
because uh you didn't have much to work
with and like we weren't paying top
dollar or anything close to it
it was it was just a yet another labor
of love
um and i hope you felt proud of
everything that happened thereafter
because genuinely think that
it might not have happened if not for
your belief in friendships so thank you
wow
it would have happened but i was honored
to be part of that journey
and to be part of helping you know you
uh you start the campaign i mean
yeah uh yeah so um so if anyone wants to
see your work
where should they go uh well uh they
should go to
creativebreed.com and um i have to
update it because
some of my recent work isn't there but
um and
generation startup is
generationstartup.com
and we were on netflix for two years as
you know um no longer but we're still on
itunes
amazon google play youtube voodoo
hoopla 2b i mean generation startup is
widely available
um and still moving people you should
know my cousin um
sent me a picture of my face on
the monitor of the airplane seat in
front of her because she was watching
your movie on the plane being like hey
look
look at this so the movie generation
startup is indeed everywhere
and i'm sure it is uh moving people um
all over the world still
to this day and you know um we're just
getting started
uh there are so many stories to tell and
we we do have to do everything we can to
try and humanize
uh this land right now because it needs
you
uh more than ever um so thank you for
everything cheryl
and i and and thank you for helping make
me more human
i genuinely had your voice in my ear the
entire campaign
where like i was like you know what
cheryl would say cheryl would be like
andrew you know you have to try to
um express your humanity so you should
know you had a big impact on me
thank you i think i think it was the
natural evolution
but i appreciate i hear you and i and i
appreciate
the thanks but um you know watching you
for me that was so i what i was most
proud of
i mean just to see you grow and
evolve um you know you were always
incredibly human
so it wasn't like you weren't human and
you became human it's just
you allowed yourself to express that
more
and more and more you know as you and
now you know
i think you're you like you just are so
comfortable
in that in that thing in place well
thank you we have to
unlock and elevate people's humanity
i feel like you know in a way what you
saw with me i think
we need to activate in more people um
you know
like that process and i think i
genuinely think our economy and our
culture
have put us many of us in boxes where
people just feel like they have like a
narrow
role to fill or like a narrow set of
things they can express
uh and that if you can let them out of
that box
uh then the sky is the limit i feel like
that that's what your work's about
um but yeah like it's i learned a lot uh
and we are just getting started as you
said
and you're gonna be there every step of
the way i'm gonna call you next time now
but this time we'd you know have more to
work with i'm sure
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you